alors en fait la mesure n'a absolument
rien de nouveau en réalité pour
quiconque connaît le monde du
renseignement se manipuler un appareil
connecté à distance on sait le faire
depuis très longtemps d'ailleurs on se
focalise sur le smartphone mais en
réalité ça s'applique aux tablettes aux
caméras connectées de vidéo surveillante
à tous les types d'appareils en fait qui
utilisent le réseau Internet et le wi-fi
en particulier ou le Bluetooth
d'ailleurs d'accord donc on a des agents
par exemple de la DGSI qui font de
l'intelligence économique qui animent
des séminaires dans les entreprises et
il est pas rare qu'il y a un agent de la
digestie qui se dissimule dans le public
et qui disent bah tiens je crois qu'il y
a un bob parmi vous et puis il vous
ressort tout votre répertoire photo
comme ça devant tout le monde en vous
disant bah vous voyez avec le bluetooth
finalement vous rendez vulnérable et en
réalité le risque dans ce cas précis par
exemple c'est la vulnérabilité au
chantage on prend vos photos dans
l'intimité on dit bon bah voilà vous
êtes marié on sait que vous avez une
deuxième vie où vous êtes par exemple
homosexuel on peut aller raconter à
votre femme ou vous pouvez choisir la
solution de facilité c'est-à-dire
prendre telle ou telle décision ou
signer
votre femme voilà par exemple voilà
voilà ça peut
c'était tout à fait ça c'est de la
manipulation par l'introduction d'un
logiciel espion euh de masquer sous un
document une photo un PDF d'un logiciel
qui permettait de prendre le contrôle
des personnalités politiques là en
l'occurrence sur l'affaire Pegasus c'est
un logiciel israélien bien sûr qu'il y
avait été détourné par des personnes
dont on dit qu'elle serait proche du
royaume chérifien et qu'elles auraient
eu justement vocation à à mettre sous
pression des hommes politiques français
voilà donc là c'est la même chose sauf
que c'est l'état d'appuyer sur un bouton
pour espionner un suspect c'est ça mais
ça se fait déjà dans le cadre
administratif il faut savoir que quand
on parle d'écoute téléphonique c'est
interne qui est en fait en réalité
obsolète aujourd'hui on parle
d'interception de sécurité donc les
interceptions de sécurité ça regroupe
tous les moyens de communication moderne
ça les emails quand vous avez un compte
Google qui enregistre tous vos mots de
passe on y a accès on a accès à vos SMS
à vos MMS à toutes les messageries vous
prenez une affaire par exemple récente
dans l'actualité l'affaire qui a opposé
de joueuse de foot à la suite d'une
agression celle de Madame bon les gens
on sait très bien qu'ils utilisent pas
nécessairement le GSM il vous dit c'est
bien c'est sécurisé on a télégramme sur
lequel on peut parler on a WhatsApp
tout ce que vous voulez bon très bien
sauf que la police a essayé toujours
d'avoir un temps d'avance sur la
criminalité ou l'un des vacances de
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait dans un prétex
ils ont placé en garde à vue ils ont
entendu très bien vous ressortez de
garde à vue 100 poursuites libres de
poursuite et pendant un an ils ont
sonorisé les véhicules ils ont sonorisé
les appartements ils ont ils ont écouté
également l'entourage en prévoyant que
ces personnes pourraient utiliser les
portables de l'entourage ils sont
revenus les chercher un an après en
disant bah voilà vous êtes effectivement
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit un
an coupable de cette agression et donc
aujourd'hui la personne est en détention
voilà quand votre voiture est sonorisée
vous pouvez parler sur l'application de
votre choix il y a pas de souci la
conversation de toute façon elle ressort
donc voilà c'est comme ça que ça se
passe donc dans le cadre administratif
il faut savoir que dans les
interceptions de sécurité vous avez le
cadre administratif c'est-à-dire les
services de renseignement qui agissent
sous l'autorité du ministre de
l'Intérieur et seulement du ministre de
l'Intérieur et vous avez les
interceptions judiciaires qui sont
ordonnées par un juge donc ça signifie
qu'on a déjà une enquête ou une
information judiciaire qui est ouverte
et donc c'est pas voilà c'est pas
n'importe quoi généralités j'ai envie
d'écouter Gilles Verdez je suis obligé
je suis obligé parce que le contexte est
particulier de dire et de rappeler à la
France qui nous écoute que la police il
faut que la police et la justice puisse
avoir accès à des éléments de preuve ou
de surveillance qui serait nécessaire
justement à la prévention des risques vu
au contenu de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui on pourrait pas dire le
contraire donc il faut que la police et
la justice soit sur souverain sur leur
territoire sur le territoire national
pour avoir accès à avoir une visibilité
sur tout ce qui s'y passe en réalité et
sans limite moi je suis pour mais par
contre c'est justement le risque de
détournement des informations et
peut-être les dérives dans l'encadrement
justement de ces procédés qui peuvent
nous poser question d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour faire la publicité d'un
article de Mediapart qui est sorti à
deux semaines qui parle des écoutes de
Matignon où on a un dossier actuellement
qui est en instruction on a eu 3
sensibles sur des personnes ciblées dans
le cadre administratif qui sont passés
en dehors des mailles du filet c'est à
dire que normalement chaque interception
sécurité doit faire l'objet d'une
signature personnelle du Premier
ministre là ça a pas été le cas et donc
il y a une enquête en courant voilà mais
juste pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent à 20h45 on peut pas écouter
n'importe qui de moi je veux écouter
Gilles Verdet il faut quand même qu'il
ait soigné en examen sur quelque chose
alors de l'Intérieur effectivement il
faut qu'il y a un juge qui supervise
donc un juge il vient pas comme ça alors
il y a deux cadres comme je vous disais
le juge est souverain effectivement donc
le juge peut ordonner une interception
de sécurité une filature alors on a un
groupe effraction à la DGSI à la police
judiciaire ou à la DGSE qui peut rentrer
à votre domicile ou qui peut rentrer
dans votre véhicule pour sonoriser votre
domicile ou votre véhicule en votre
absence ça c'est légal depuis très
longtemps donc en fait si vous voulez il
y a rien de nouveau l'administratif en
fait c'est fait pour la prévention le
judiciaire c'est la répression c'est en
fait ça sert à confondre des personnes
suspectées ou à les innocenter très
important à les confondre ou à les
innocenter donc ça les surveillance
servent aux deux on pense que c'est fait
pour confondre mais en réalité ça peut
aussi finalement disculper des personnes
qui seraient suspectées donc mais quand
le que j'ordonne une interception c'est
qu'il y a une suspicion c'est que vous
êtes désigné par quelqu'un et donc à ce
moment-là les interceptions font partie
des modalités d'investigation et en
réalité de l'administratif sert à la
prévention donc dans le cas de préventif
effectivement ça se fait déjà je veux
dire on sait le faire depuis très
longtemps et comme je vous le disais en
fait c'est une modalité par rapport à
d'autres n'ayez aucune illusion sur le
fait que vous êtes alors je vais pas
dire vous êtes tous surveillés mais vous
êtes tous surveillables je dirais vous
êtes tous surveillables faut pas penser
que derrière chaque citoyen français il
y a un policier moi bien sûr ancien
agent du renseignement j'ai eu accès à
des secrets d'État pendant 10 ans je
veux dire très honnêtement je le sais
j'ai des copains et que ça qui m'ont
bien prévenu que j'étais
administratif dans le cas de préventif
alors les choses sont bien faites la loi
est bien écrite il y a des professions
qui sont exemple de toute modalités de
surveillance dans le cadre administratif
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas être
surveillé si on est une personnalité
politique personnalité locale
d'opposition parce que vous imaginez
bien que la majorité pourrait s'en
servir pour trouver des choses à redire
sur les opposants si vous êtes avocat la
retranscription d'une conversation entre
un
avocat
d'ailleurs Sarkozy alors il y a eu les
écoutes tout ça
alors là effectivement sauf si l'avocat
et lui-même suspect donc ça il a pas
échappé à la condamnation donc preuve en
ex ça pose pas de problème en réalité
sauf que sauf que quand vous êtes je
veux dire suspect quand vous avez des
conversations des échanges avec votre
avocat c'est pour justement monter une
stratégie de défense et donc la justice
ou même l'État n'a pas à les s'immiscer
dans dans des conversations
le secret des sources est respecté donc
il y a eu d'ailleurs des affaires la
DGSI a eu à répondre justement des
investigations menées sur des cibles ou
des journalistes parce que le secret des
sources doit être respecté donc il y a
tout un panel comme ça de de de
profession ou de statuts qui sont
exemples justement de de de de la
possibilité d'être surveillé et on a une
commission de contrôle qui est composée
d'un magistral et précisé par un
magistrat elle est présidée par un
magistrat et par et elle est composée de
5 parlementaires justement qui doivent
se concerter toutes les semaines sur
tous les dossiers pour pouvoir justement
vérifier leur conformité leur légalité